[Music]
you
I'm Eric Paree I'm the Associate
Director of the arthur c-- clark center
for human imagination and i'm here on
behalf of our center director Sheldon
Brown and I'm so pleased to have the
opportunity to stand up because as many
of you know who've been to events like
this before I love to talk about arthur
c clarke and he was so inspiring to me
and apropos to tonight's topic he was
nominated for the nobel prize and didn't
win either so i guess sir arthur could
relate and i've been thinking about
blessings and family and to introduce
our associate director dr. Keating dr.
Keating has many blessings and of course
his blessings include his lovely family
and we have to give a big thanks to his
wife Sarah because she just had twins
ten days ago and so she let Brian out of
the house so congratulations Brian and
Sarah you have so many blessings and we
are very appreciative of your coming so
the other blessing that Brian has is his
ability to investigate science and tell
us about it he is a fantastic and noted
teacher here at UCSD giving lectures on
all kinds of things not only physics but
even things like poetry but what most
inspires me about what Brian does is he
builds telescopes and telescopes are
just so cool the neat thing about the
telescopes that Brian will tell us about
is you can't look through them they're
actually opaque that's because they look
at different things than visible light
than what the things that we typically
think of telescopes so if no further ado
I'd like to welcome our associate
director of the arthur c clarke center
for human imagination Bryan Keating
I like that you applaud me for having
twins okay I had the easy part
so it's a real pleasure to be here I
think the library UC San Diego for many
things in particular helping me in the
production of this book which I'm so
proud of the way it turned out and I
really wouldn't have turned out this
well without the help of Linda Classen
and others at the UC system library and
people that I'll thank at the end I'd
also thank my fellow co-director Erik
very the double doctor as we call him MD
ph.d for all his help in shepherding the
arthur c-- clark center for human
imagination while our dear leader is
recovering from from a cold so yes so
it's been a week of first for me so
we've had our first twins so i like to
show this so i get the oohs and the ahhs
and then i'm gonna show a picture of a
kitten playing with string no I'm not
gonna do that I think that would be a
cuteness overload so these are my two
newest bangs in the universe Miriam and
and Emmanuelle and they are quite a
blessing indeed as Eric pointed out so
the other thing I'm blessed to do here
is work with this team of cosmetologist
I mean cosmologists these are actually
many people make that mistake and have
you ever thought about why cosmology and
cosmetology sounds so similar it's
because they share the same prefix Kazem
and that's not an accident Kazem in
greek means beautiful or appearance and
in the context of the beauty salon where
i spend a lot of my time the the Kazem
that study is the face though of the
clientele that beauty parlor what we get
to see is the adornment of the universe
the beautiful sign that the universe
shows us and we get to investigate it as
there except by building technology and
these are the people that do it ok
professors get to take a lot of credit
for the accomplishments but these are
the people some of whom are in the room
today I'm so proud of them these are my
students and my colleagues professor kim
arnold and my many many graduate
students and undergrads that work here
at UC san diego to make us one of the
top cosmology programs in the world
so the adornment the face that the
universe presents to us for generations
seem like an infinite
infinitely dense barrier that could not
be penetrated it could only be
penetrated with the human mind or the
human vision was having had a limitation
we weren't able to see beyond what was
conceived to be a basic crystalline
sphere onto which the Stars were affixed
in permanent fashion and the only things
that moved around were planets in fact
the word planet means wanderer and
there's only a handful of planets
literally five planets that could be
seen with the naked eye and so the
ancients would would speculate well what
was beyond the limits of our vision what
was beyond the limits of what you could
see through your eyes or even through a
telescope and it turned out that the
technology to investigate that this this
is a woodcut which was produced
soon after the invention of Adobe
Photoshop and actually no it was
produced in the 1800s and it's it's it's
a woodcut no one knows exactly who did
it and I've color are showing a
colorized version here but it shows this
this one this this wonderer and he's
looking out into what may lie beyond the
limits of the human visible sensation I
think it wonderfully depicts what we're
trying to do and this quest has taken us
on a quest that has overthrown paradigms
generation after generation the first
sort of paradigm that that cosmology or
the study of astronomical objects
indicated was that we were not the
center of the earth the earth was
thought to be flat it sure looks flat
and if you use a map and in any context
you'll know that the maps are always
drawn on a flat cartographic projection
and that's in order so that you can
actually use these devices if you had to
carry around the globe everywhere to get
around to be quite inconvenient so it
sure looks flat to us but actually we
all take it for granted that the earth
isn't flat we also take for granted that
the that the earth is not the center of
the solar system although it really took
the conjecture of Copernicus
observations of Kepler and the really
convincing arguments that were
demonstrated by Galileo when he first
turned a small refracting telescope to
the heavens in the summer of 1609 and
this telescope was one that he could
look through and connected to the focal
point of that telescope was his eyeball
and his retina was connected very
closely to his brain and he was able to
things that had vexed philosophers and
and physicists for millennia beforehand
he didn't actually prove that we're not
the center of the solar system he just
showed there are other centers of the
solar system namely the planet Jupiter
which has moons that orbit around it not
the earth so that was convincing
evidence at least that there are
multiple centers and so therefore the
earth could not be the center of the
universe and the gabbie solar system was
considered to be the universe back then
the next step out in cosmology well once
we assure we once we found out that we
weren't the center of the solar system
our egos really took a pounding and so
we next started to to conjecture that
well we might not be the center of the
solar system but we're the center of the
galaxy and all the maps of the galaxy
that were made by the most notable
astronomers of the 1800s depicted the
earth being placed at the center of the
galaxy sure we weren't the center of the
of the solar system but at least we were
the center of the galaxy and that debate
raged until the early part of the 19 of
the 1900s when astronomers named Shapley
and Curtis really went through a debate
and found out that not only are we not
the center of the of our galaxy we're
not the only galaxy in the universe in
fact there are many other galaxies in
the universe this is a picture of the
Hubble Deep Field and this Hubble Deep
Field shows many many tons of different
galaxies in addition to the Milky Way
galaxy so we know we're not the center
of the solar system we're not the center
of the earth the solar system the galaxy
now the question is are we the center of
something called the multiverse are
there multiple universes in which our
universe what we used to think of as the
whole shebang it's just one nondescript
in an insignificant universe within an
infinity of possible other universes and
I have a cartoon graph of this you know
there could be another universe and
we're at the center of this of the
sphere of observation called the horizon
that we can look out and see things but
there could be another universe located
either distance from us in space perhaps
one separated from us in time perhaps
separated by dimensionality inhibiting
or inhabiting rather in an in an extra
dimension so-called extra dimension that
we have no access to so these are
delightful things that were for long
periods of time thought to be purely
speculative until it was found that if
there was if the multiverse existed it
would sort of be a consequence of a
theory known as inflation inflation I
like to call the spark that ignited the
Big Bang and if the Big Bang had this
ignition source like a fuse that ignited
it then it would leave shrapnel behind
it would leave behind a signature not in
the form of light not in the form of
heat even but in the form of ripples in
space-time itself these ripples are
called gravitational waves and so if
inflation took place in the Big Bang's
earliest trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second as theoretical
physicists told us we would see a
pattern on the universe's oldest light a
light source called the cosmic microwave
background radiation that is a fossil
relic of the universe's formation of the
elements a process that took place in
the first 20 minutes or so after the Big
Bang I always like to point out that all
the elements that we are eventually
going to be made of took place and were
formed during a period of time about 20
minutes which is shorter than the sitcom
The Big Bang Theory so it's pretty
amazing when you think about it in that
way so we sent out and I designed along
with colleagues of mine at Caltech and
other places an instrument called bicep
- I designed bicep one we upgraded it
because it became known as bicep - kind
of like the iPhone iPhone X iPhone
triple act whatever I hope hope don't be
a xxx but but anyway I need to keep this
rated G this this telescope is a simple
Galilean telescope it uses lenses lenses
that the human eye can't see through
because these lenses are opaque to
visible light but they transmit
microwave light quite quite beautifully
and they refract or bend the waves of
microwaves that come from this distant
heat source called the Cosmic Microwave
Background those rays get focused onto
not Galileo's retina but onto these
exciting detectors called
superconducting transit transition edge
sensing bolometer x' these detectors
transduce the heat waves and convert
them into electrical signals from that
point we can digitize them we can store
that data and we can analyze that data
and we can make maps but we couldn't do
it from San Diego as nice
is to live in San Diego we had to take
it to a place that's much colder much
drier and much better in many ways than
San Diego could ever be it's also quite
distant it's called the South Pole
Antarctica this is the amundsen-scott
South Pole Station this was reached
first time in 1911 and it was exactly
like many of the the quests of the early
part of the 1900s to be first to reach
something first to stake a flag in the
ground as we did on the lunar surface it
was the moon shot of the early 1900s and
just like the moon shot we have been
back to the moon since 1974 or something
like that 40 years plus people didn't go
back to the South Pole until about 40
years after it was first reach for the
for by human beings in 1911 and it goes
to show you that sometimes people just
want to get there first and that happens
a lot not just an exploration of the
earth but also in science as well as I
as I will hopefully discuss so I was
there a couple times you have to prove
that you were there you have take a
selfie and then soon after this did this
instrument was deployed we claimed that
we saw evidence for this inflationary
epoch that was imprinting itself on the
pattern of heat called the Cosmic
Microwave Background we saw these swirls
he's twisting curling patterns in the
sky that theoreticians had told us would
be indicative of the inflationary
explosive origin of the universe of the
Big Bang's
of the big banks creation itself so we
observed this signal and that was
tantamount to providing the most direct
evidence that we could have ever
imagined for inflation and then the
other piece of the puzzle was that if
inflation occurred it seemed to mandate
that there were multiverse that there
was a multiverse that there are multiple
universes in addition to ours so the lot
chain of logic that we used was we found
this pattern it was meant to indicate
the origin of the universe in an
inflationary epoch and inextricably
intertwined with the inflationary epoch
was the multiverse so it was incredibly
exciting we made this discovery it made
front-page headlines in every single
newspaper in the world here's the New
York Times in the lower right corner you
can see space ripples indicate Big
Bang's
smoking-gun that spark that ignited the
Big Bang you see on top
conference that was held there's a viral
video here of one of the founding
fathers of inflation Andrei Linde about
two million hits the first day that it
was released but that wasn't all when I
was gratifying piece of public relations
that we got was in the onion so the
onion you can see here it said the top
theoretical physicist and R&B singers
meet to debate the meaning of forever so
they really have these they didn't
really convene these people but there's
Diana Ross and there's Michiyo Kaku ok
the father of string theory so on the
bottom it says panelists discuss whether
it's theoretically possible to give you
my heart forever ok and they talk about
the last thing we see primordial b-mode
polarization a twisting curling pattern
of microwaves indicative of inflation
and that says whether or not you can
tell this the parallels between this and
the love between india arie and her man
all of which seemed to have existed
since the universe's infancy so I
thought that was fabulous unfortunately
this was the last sort of hopeful moment
in this in this and the saga of this
detection of this incredible finding
that we made and soon after we began to
get doubts and doubts were and questions
were put to our team as to whether or
not we had seen this imprimatur of
inflation this twisting pattern coming
from the universes after afterglow or if
we had instead seen something much more
prosaic but much more all pervasive
namely dust so there's dust in this room
there's dust that follows my kids are
out my five kids around I can't believe
that but there's dust in the
interstellar wind as well and this dust
is made from the exploded remnants of
supernovae that shred shed out all of
their material into the medium that
surrounds them and these and these
particles of a former star are actually
made of things that are very common like
iron in fact the iron that flows through
your blood right now was once the
product of an exploded Sun so it's quite
amazing to think that you actually have
star dust that's flowing through your
veins right now and this was flowing in
the cosmos and we believe it got in the
way of the measurement that we were
trying to that we sought to measure so
we did an analysis with that with a
former competitor of ours a satellite a
space-based satellite that was a million
miles away from the earth called Planck
and they and they were originally our
arch-nemesis in some way almost the
villain of this story was the planks
right and and then at the end we kind of
beat our telescopic swords into
plowshares and we combined forces to
reveal what we had actually seen was not
the universe's earliest inflationary
moments instead disappointingly we had
to retract that claim and so the story
of the book is how did that claim came
to come to be made why it was so
important what it was like the the fear
the pressure the the ultimate
embarrassment of this of this affair and
then how we literally pick ourselves up
dust ourselves off and get back to work
so you can guess at the end of this was
the you know a whooshing sound that went
by and that was my Nobel Prize die add
insult to injury in a certain sense less
than a year later I came to work and I
said to one of my graduate students I
got an interesting piece of mail today
and it said from the Swedish royal
academy of sciences Nobel foundation and
I said to my graduate student Fred I
said huh it was what I deserved I should
have got it last week because it was in
early October it was right after the
Nobel Prizes had been announced for 2015
and it was an invitation for me Bryan
Keating the humble correspondent to
nominate the next year's winners of the
Nobel Prize in Physics in 2016 I thought
that was incredible so I ignored the
part at the upper rights a strictly
confidential okay if you're out there at
Nobel and Sweden you know I know this is
my last shot at nominating people but
you know I'm an academic right so I
treat everything as a scholar would so I
got this letter it asked me to nominate
people at first I thought it was a great
honor and then I started to feel that
there were some problems with the Nobel
Prize in fact some problems that are
highlighted in this letter that I've
underlined here and then I'll discuss in
the next couple of moments the last few
moments of my talk so I went back on a
scholar academic went back to Alfred
Nobel's will written by hand in 1895 a
year before he died after reading the
headline in the para region newspaper
that he had picked up that said Alfred
Nobel the merchant of death is dead now
obviously he's reading it so reports of
his demise were exaggerated but it told
him what life would be like and how he
would be remembered if he were to die
the next day he the inventor of dynamite
had killed according to this article
more people in history than any other
person he wanted
to rectify his public image he wrote a
will be and he gave all of his money
with a little exception that I'll
explain in a minute
all to this Nobel Prize that bears his
name
he had no spouse he had no children so
this is his next of kin so I read his
will I'm not gonna read through the
whole thing I just highlight three
different clauses here one is that the
prize was supposed to be given for the
benefit benefit of mankind to discovery
or invention that conferred the greatest
benefit to mankind made during the
preceding year and this prize was
supposed to be given to somebody whether
or not he is Scandinavian and we'll get
into that so there's been a lot of
controversy even just as recently as
last week involving Nobel Prizes of all
different shapes and sizes so they've
been prizes given to people that some
consider terrorist there have been
prizes given to the president United
States after he took office 11 days
prior to the awards eligibility and even
last year the prize given in literature
to Bob Dylan so these have all caused
controversy I'm not I don't talk about
the propriety of these Awards in my book
my expert my subject matter expertise is
physics so let's go back and ask
ourselves and discoveries made in
physics or the physical sciences let's
test your knowledge first okay so I want
you to raise your hand a B or C which of
these three different inventions or
discoveries won the Nobel Prize so raise
your hand if you think a the RNA
molecule won the Nobel Prize okay only
one person well now B is the periodic
table which I'll remind you has an
element named nobelium okay after Alfred
Nobel and C looks like a lighthouse okay
so B who thinks be periodic table come
on that's a big one okay and then see
the lighthouse and then raise your hand
if you don't like raising your hand okay
nobody likes to go of course it's C it
was given to gustav delenn in 1912 for
the invention of automatic regulators
for use in conjunction with gas
accumulator for illuminating lighthouses
and buoys okay that is just so important
and it really just revolutionizes our
daily life now we've had many noblest
here in San Diego I want to show one
that Linda helped me get a picture of
this is a picture taken by Ansel Adams
at UCSD and it's an original print and I
was able to get at courtesy of Linda
and it shows him in front of his
eponymous hall there's a hall that's
named after him we also had a Nobel
Prize winner that was here that did win
the Nobel Prize in 2016 not my nominee
but but someone else and his name is
Duncan Hall Dane and he actually did the
work that netted him his Nobel Prize
while he was a professor here and then
some University in the East Coast a big
Ivy League school put a bag of money in
front of him and he and he and he went
to Princeton so good for them and he's
been at Princeton and for many decades
and that's a picture of him when he came
back to UCSD last year and he brought
his actual Nobel Prize with him okay so
I've been writing this book this is the
day I turned in the first draft of this
book losing the Nobel Prize in which I
dissect that a Nobel Prize process who
has given to why so seemingly so sexist
and it's had racism in its past all
these things that made me so angry about
the Nobel Prize and really changed my
perspective on it and it really came to
see it as almost like an idol where
people that are the most rational people
in the world physicists that are used to
looking at pure evidence and they were
basically moving and I mean that's the
Nobel Prize you can see it's glowing
almost white-hot and people are in just
in love with this thing it's amazing and
I just look someone's taking a picture
with it I mean I felt so embarrassed for
these people okay that day that they
worship a little an engraved golden
image of Alfred Nobel how could they I
mean that's disgusting and wait a second
who's that so even I somehow would the
phone got I took a picture I took a
selfie even though I've been writing
this book so this prize has a power
unique in human history and I want to
close with one of the problems I talk
about a lot in the book and it has a
connection to UC San Diego as well so
Alfred Nobel's will begins by saying I
do hereby say after thorough discussion
whatever I want to give to my son to my
nephews hit I can't pronounce college
amar and Ludwig Nobel bequeath the sum
of two hundred thousand Swedish crowns
each and to my niece Mina I give 100
thousand okay so the men got twice as
much as the women okay so some say is
this the route of the Nobel Prizes you
know a legendary sexism well maybe but
some of the sexism is actually more
pernicious so right here at UC
we had two of the most preeminent
astronomers who ever lived
Margot Burbidge who's still thankfully
quite very much alive and via Reuben who
passed through UCSD for several years
under the tutelage of Margot burbage
those are also portraits of her taken by
Ansel Adams and I assure you
astronomers female and male both spend
their time at microscopes very rarely
okay III don't remember the last time I
used a microscope but these women seem
to be doing it maybe that was all the
rage anyway they both made foundational
contributions to Nobel prize-worthy
subjects in fact Margaret contributed to
the Nobel Prize that was won by William
Fowler up at Caltech so he benefited
from these observations that Margaret
was uniquely suited to make she helped
to write the paper that ended up winning
him the Nobel Prize in part and then
Vere Rubin then it was denied a Nobel
Prize she never won the Nobel Prize even
though she made a discovery that almost
every astronomer considers to be Noble
worthy and even the only two women in
history who've ever won the Nobel Prize
in Physics they won it grudgingly Marie
Curie won it in 1903 for radioactivity
and the findings that she made with her
husband Pierre and actually the the
Nobel Prize Committee was not going to
give it to her until her husband said
I'm gonna turn down my share of the
Nobel Prize unless you give it to my
wife as well because she did most of the
work and then Maria Maher who is here at
UC San Diego for many decades or many
years rather and she was a she was a
nuclear physicist she was nominated 27
times before she won the Nobel Prize
that's almost twice as many times as
Albert Einstein was nominated now why
should that be surprising well Albert
Einstein besides being recognized as one
of the greatest physicists in history
was it you and the early years of the
Nobel Prize Jews were almost expressly
forbidden from winning the Nobel Prize
why because of a procedure that's still
in place in the Nobel Prize statutes
today which is that if you win a Nobel
Prize you're automatically eligible to
nominate the winners for the rest of
your life so you're one of this
privileged class of physicists that gets
to nominate Nobel Prize winners every
year so the Germans who were doing some
of the best physics in the world at the
time they were led by what was known as
Hitler's chief of Aryan physics and
was Filip Lonard and he said that Jews
like Einstein practiced world bluffing
Jewish physics there was theoretical
physics it wasn't German physics which
is experimental physics so I found that
quite ironic that they that she was
actually denied longer than Einstein by
almost a factor of two and so she was
the last woman to win it that was 54
years ago and when she did win it the
headline in the newspaper at the San
Diego union-tribune said San Diego
housewife wins Nobel Prize so even that
was a little bit sexist and it's not so
surprising so this is the medal of the
Swedish royal Academy that is the
official name of the Nobel Prize
medallion they were able to give me
permission to print this in the book and
I I bet they regret that but but anyway
it shows two women on it it shows mother
nature and it shows the genius of
science so these are two women and I
thought back I've been hearing a lot
about this this interesting sociological
test and I want to see if it makes sense
to you so you see here two different
women there's one woman there's another
woman and then you see a dude in the
middle and there's something called the
Bechdel test is anyone heard of the
Bechdel test it says when two women are
talking on screen in a movie it's almost
always the case because of the way that
shows are written that they're talking
about a man that their conversation
involves a man so in this case this is a
failure of the bat it means that they're
centered on this on this man Alfred
Nobel and in fact there are only two
women have ever won it means that
there's only two more female Nobel Prize
winners than there have been female
popes it's pretty interesting okay so
why should we care about this well it's
humanity's superlative award and I found
in the writing of it that they were not
adhering to what Alfred Nobel expressly
wrote in his will and when somebody dies
and they have no next of kin there's
really nothing to advocate for them
other than their will then they really
disavowed much of what they've done and
I talked about how and the state lawyer
might view their will throughout the
book and so with some help of some
colleagues we created a community called
losing the Nobel Prize or where people
can nominate winners who were unjustly
or unfairly denied the prize and make
changes to the prizes structure namely
to change some of the statutes which are
pretty ossified and have not changed and
in some cases in almost 50 years so it's
high time that it
Changez and so I'd like to leave you all
with a word of thanks to many of the
people here I show people at UCSD in
general in white that were just
instrumental in making this book a
possibility and then in red special
attention to my graduate students
because as I say in the book a lot of
the book is kind of an exploration of
what it means to be a professor to be a
mentor to graduate students and to be
the weighty responsibility because I was
told once that in Russian the word
scientist means one who was taught and
it really means that to be a scientist
means you have to be a teacher and you
were taught by somebody else so I asked
forgiveness to my students some of whom
were here for being such a bad teacher
to you in the last year when I was
writing this book and I hope I beseech
you for forgiveness but I hope that you
will all join with me in this new quest
to redeem the prize that is humanity's
highest accolade thank you very much so
now I'd like to call up my good friend
dr. David Brin
I just how much how much better when
they're edible I remember the first time
I saw a nobel-prize up close it was
Richard Fineman it was 1970 and Richard
Feynman had drilled a hole through his
and it was hanging from a chain around
his neck it was 1970 and he was wearing
a turtleneck and he bowed to me and it
jangled in my direction and he said may
I borrow your date for this dance he
took her out on the dance floor it was a
little ditty called in-a-gadda-da-vida
that last 20 minutes and the he later
had a paper that the turtleneck is not
an item of male clothing we need to bend
so within five minutes he was almost
choking and he he came back and he said
you you must take my place well like an
idiot I misunderstood him and became a
physics major
so the Nobel Prize can have pernicious
effects in many ways Bryan it was an
honor to get to read this book in
manuscript and and to see how how it was
developing over time and it's certainly
getting an awful lot of attention and
Bryan sent around an email saying my
dream has come true I have a book my
dream would come true if I were if I
were instead of a low church physicist a
high church physicist like you so there
in any event we have a number of
questions and we're going to be limiting
it to about 15 minutes and then you
don't have a chance to buy the book and
and get it signed by Bryan is this your
first signing I find once before I can't
well alright it's his first real signing
here at his home at UCSD and we have sat
on this stage before we were
with Andy Friedman we were the three
physicists we've done it three times on
three different topics
perhaps we'll do it again this summer
one was about the multiverse that's true
and a topic which is of course raised by
the bicep problems so I'd like to dial
in on a couple of your complaints about
the about the Nobel the defenders say it
draws attention and draws people into
science but at the same time that you're
concerned that it emphasizes competition
over collaboration yeah could you
explicate yeah so so one of the rules of
the Nobel Prize which was not one of
Alfred Nobel's stipulations was that the
Nobel Prize could go to at most three
people and actually it found it's
actually found in Alfred Nobel's will
that I should go to one person so at
first blush you might say oh great you
know they really are being generous
they're giving it to three times as many
people but actually in the early years
there was some concern that that maybe
even three wasn't enough even though
science in the time of Alfred Nobel was
typically done by by one or two people
at most and it was much less
collaborative than sciences today so
bicep was done an experiment done by 49
collaborators working together over a
period of almost a decade in the case of
the Nobel Prize the stipulation says
that you should award it for a discovery
made during the preceding year by a
single person so it's come to many
people's minds that the restriction of
three people causes a lot of competition
where competition need not take place
and in fact the Peace Prize has no such
restriction the Peace Prize can be won
by thousands of people in fact or
institutions it can be won by entire
institutions and in that case you wonder
you know does that dilute the the the
you know the the wonderful allure of the
prize does it take away their motivation
I would say not because they're
committed to what they're doing just the
same way a physicist wouldn't
necessarily do the work for the prize
itself but as I say in the book the the
physicists who are striving to win the
prize as I
in the book I was I don't think that's
really so much the problem it's really I
make the analogy of the Academy Awards
so the Academy Awards I don't think any
actor actor says my whole goal is to win
an Academy Award but they theatrical
movie producers they sure as heck want
their their their their talent to win
Academy Awards and it's very important
to them and that's why if you go to the
National Science Foundation website or
you go to the Department of Energy or
NASA the lists for you all the Nobel
laureates that they've had on there that
they've funded and produced and even our
university will recommend that and it
counts towards our rankings amongst
other universities as well so there's
subtle pressures that get put in place
and I think that that's that's to the
detriment of the way science is done
today as opposed to in 1895 when Alfred
wrote his will
well we'll talk again in in ten minutes
about competition which you know some
people believe that it's not necessarily
a bad thing competition in its own right
but the notion that the Nobel in it when
we were talking about these very very
large collaborative groups it the
counter-argument is that it would wind
up being the groups that would always
win and then you don't have any kind of
bragging rights because I'm a winner of
the Nobel Prize if your paper was along
with you know fifty or sixty other
people that dilutes it yeah but it's not
such a bad thing right so so there's no
law of physics that says that the Nobel
Prize is the thing that one should
aspire to and that is really the proof
or the are the authority that solidifies
authority and conveys authority in the
physical sciences but it's almost
elevated to this idol-like status and I
compare it in the book to almost a form
of religion where scientists have
holiday set aside for the Nobel Prize
ceremonies they have feast they actually
conduct the award ceremony on the
anniversary of Alfred Nobel's death
every year which is kind of McCobb and
they also have a high priesthood they
have saints they have sinners the
apostates like myself and then they of
course have instead of a crucified
they have a gilded graven image of the
portrait of Alfred Nobel on the golden
cat the golden calf so so I I claim that
even the hyper-rational mostly secular
scientist that make up my divinely
inspired colleagues suffer from a little
bit of a religious affiliation with the
nobel pro but haven't there been
attempts to spread things out a bit by
adding adding prizes the Fields Medal in
in mathematics and and various other
national national academy prizes and
things like that of course the
presidential medal has been diluted in a
completely different way because
alternating administrations have been
using it for political reasons right so
go ahead yeah I mean I don't think that
there's any question that the Nobel
Prize is the superlative award in all of
humanity I know I don't think there's a
close second to it there are other
prizes that are actually worth three
times as much as the Nobel Prize in
Physics alone but I think I've heard it
said by winners of those prizes that
they would trade in the money and that
award for just this fraction of a Nobel
Prize and you know it really it really
shows you how elevated this prize that's
handed out by mainly you know 500 mostly
white men and Sweden how it's become
such a symbol of aspiration for as I
said funding agencies individual
researchers universities etc well there
was a scandal just in the newspapers
just yesterday about the Academy of
Literature in Sweden where the head
female head of the literary Academy in
in Sweden had to resign because she was
she was forced out she was forced out by
what appears to be a
a very obstinate bunch of shall we say
male troglodyte I think that's putting
it mildly I mean her husband committed
adultery and for some reason she's
taking the fall for his so she's bendy
and removed from this and the king of
Sweden is now threatening to may perhaps
not hold the ceremonies this year
they're the Prize in Literature so a
part of the book is written an attempt
to reform the Nobel Prize so it doesn't
suffer these kinds of fates because I
think you know when you look at it and
you say to me you know I've had I've had
five female graduate students and I
think it's important to have role models
and we're blessed to have had Maria
Mayer here but she was 1954 and 1963
rather is 54 years ago and I think you
know when there's there's a lot of
people that I can look to and I look to
her as a role model as well but I think
it sends a it sends a very negative
message when fewer than 1% of all
laureates you know are come from you
know 50% of the population and I think
that's it's detrimental and I think part
of it you know comes down to you know
the way that this election process is
ingrained by the previous winners being
automatically entitled to nominate next
year's winners and and there's many
simple reforms that I propose in the
book that the Nobel Prize Committee
could take if they want to save
themselves cuz I think if the prize were
to get boycotted it would start to lose
this luster that has been responsible
for why it's had the allure that it's
had for so many a century in more now
well things do change the Hugo Awards in
science fiction for instance this last
year of the I think 32 authors who are
nominated for various fiction Awards
novel novelette and so on I think maybe
four or five or male mmm so so things
things sometimes pass through a an
overshoot and perhaps we'll have that
sort of thing in the Nobel yeah that's
the hope of this of this book and the
website that we've created it's know we
both know one of the recent winners Kip
Thorne of Caltech I remember when I was
there
all in awe of richard fineman he was a
very young physicist and they were
talking about his potential to win this
prize and he just did only not for any
of the Prairie paths that he was on when
he was young he won for LIGO detection
of gravitational waves and the brilliant
thing that most people think that he did
was the choice of the of the team that
he would then be a senior member of all
right yeah it's like they say I think in
Russian the most important choice is who
you choose for your parents and so in
probably my twins chose well no but in
physics you get to choose your parents
in a sense yeah choosing which team
you're a member of exactly and he was a
sort of automatically became a leader of
that team and therefore if that team
succeeded right so the comparison has
been made between winning something out
of virtue and winning something out of a
lottery but there's a ground in between
where it's a matter of your own choosing
the right team that is going to
inevitable not inevitably but have a
very high likelihood of making a noble
win
yeah and then also living long enough to
receive it so one of his colleagues that
create co-creator of LIGO experiment was
named Ron driver Ron driver was
responsible for building a LIGO
experiment in many ways in its most
critical phase and in the in the early
in 1980s or so Barry Barris took over
from him but he was really responsible
for the founding of this experiment now
what LIGO detected that won its Nobel
Prize was the in spiraling collapse and
crash of these two massive black holes
located more than a billion light years
from Earth these signals traveling for
over a billion years reached the earth
and when they reached the earth they
created a signal in the LIGO detectors
that eventually netted them their Nobel
Prize but the signal wasn't what came in
in September and by the time they
announced the detection it was February
they had missed the Nobel Prize
deadlines that I could have nominated
them for and had I been able to and had
they announced I would have nominated
Ronald Reber but they didn't so he ended
up dying a year later and that was the
year he was eligible to win the Nobel
Prize but because of the rules that they
changed in 1974
what tape overlooked a couple of times
first white Swedish men who have been
allowed to receive the Nobel Prize
posthumously they don't allow posthumous
prizes so the Nobel Prize Committee
wrote him out of the story
and said and said well he was a part of
it in the beginning but then he left the
prize but left the project well that
could be said of any of them including
Kip Thorne I mean he went on to do other
things as well so I think there's
there's there's problems with the with
the way the prize is awarded that ends
up affecting how the population at large
the general audio
views the Nobel Prize and the scientific
discoveries that are made would you
consider the possibility of having a
sort of a multi-pronged approach in that
since anybody who's gonna get the prize
now from now on is going to be a member
of a team or one thing that I've seen in
science fiction stories is oh this is
this is cute in astrophysics journals
papers from before 1945
there's always thanks to their funders
and all that and what they thank their
computers because the computers were
usually a list of women which you saw in
that movie hidden figures the women who
did the real work and one of them got
all the nobel prize money and that was
the wife of Albert Einstein he thanked
his computer and his wife he had married
a computer I don't
but the point is that thanking your
computer's stopped but twenty years from
now if you don't thank your computer all
your lights in your house won't go on
for the rest of you is gonna win them
about prom
so that was circular to get back to the
notion that science fiction has
predicted that computers or a eyes will
be involved in these teams do you think
that it might be a possibility that
there might be in the prize whatever
institution and so all the junior people
could at least take a nibble of that
portion of the prize and then some
posthumous a couple of posthumous and
then you have your three do you think
that sort of thing would it would be
more nuanced yeah but do you think that
would help to address your look if they
can figure it out in the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts how to give it a lot
of awards to multiple people to not to
you know to notify who is nominated so
when I received this letter I also was
informed that I will not be notified no
one will ever know that I was a
nominator unless I read a book about it
no one will ever know I'm for fifty
years so they keep not only who I
nominated sealed longer than the Kennedy
assassination files they keep sealed my
identity you know and wants to know why
that was because you know you always
hear what is it what is the the cliche
it's just an honor to be nominated right
so they deny people the the the benefit
to their career of the you know being
able to say that they were nominated
unless somebody writes a book right so
the question is you know can they learn
from Hollywood I actually say in the
book we have a lot to learn from
Hollywood and in fact there's a parallel
growth in the size of collaborations and
the size of movie staffs that are needed
to make a motion picture
so they both gone up exponentially since
the 1940s as technology is improved and
all the producers will share an Oscar
right so why can't that be with the
Nobel Prize as well there's no law of
physics that prevents it oh that's very
interesting Patrick the program manager
for the Clark Center suggested this
question playing devil's advocate I'm
sure some people will say Brian the
Nobel might not be
but it still gets people excited about
new discoveries about scientific
research and that's tremendous during a
time which support for that let alone
science feels like it's waning so how do
you respond to yeah I mean I absolutely
agree on and I don't begrudge I mean to
the extent that people know a living
scientist now that Stephen Hawking is
unfortunately no longer with us it might
be Neil deGrasse Tyson or a couple of
other people they don't I'm not so sure
that they know who the Nobel laureates
are much less what they do and many
people have speculated that the rise in
the Nobel Prize coincided with the rise
of media attention and certainly in
Sweden where they claimed that a hundred
million people tuned in every year not
Sweden ten times the population of
Sweden but but around the world to to
witness these events on the Internet
so I think it is good to celebrate
science and there are Reformation there
are prizes that take place that award
more than just a few people as the Nobel
Prize a literal handful of people and I
think we could learn from that as well
to to you know to popularize science but
in most cases the new prizes are kind of
derided because you'll have George
Clooney presenting a prize to a
physicist you know and and they think
that demean science I don't think so I
think anything you can do to to
illustrate the excitement of science of
passion of science and take away this
outdated notion that's just some lone
genius working in isolation that comes
up as some in Eureka moment that that's
what a scientist is because that's not
what a scientist is the how many of you
out here I've seen the Paul Newman and
Reggie Robinson movie the prize Oh if
you haven't this is highly pertinent
maybe it's a lovely movie I have not
seen it you have no well it's it's about
the Nobel Prize and Paul Newman plays an
American who is one the literary prize
of Ed Ritchie Robinson is up is going to
win for physics and the East Germans do
something nefarious the East Germans so
yeah well it's it's actually it's a it's
a very good movie you should give it now
you were having this book some examples
of your poetry of a poem about it
showing his incredible resentment
against dust yes
and you give your academic genealogy
stretching back through time you see
you're the student of the student if the
student go on yeah so I have a genealogy
a family tree that goes back to the late
1500s
it goes back thanks to the source of all
wisdom and knowledge Wikipedia I'm able
to trace back my genealogy 17
generations back to a scientist Leibniz
who worked in the late 1500s before
Galileo ever turned a telescope to the
sky Leibniz was the great competitor of
Isaac Newton well this is a different
lesson Lawton is not oh I see okay but
the but the the notion that your
genealogy is descended from student
teachers yes one of my former graduate
students Darcy Barron who is now a prize
postdoctoral fellow at UC Berkeley she
had this wonderful plaque made for me
showing all of my advisers advise
advisers and separate along a chain I
thought was so beautiful so I had my
illustrator Schaeffer Grubb who designed
all the plots in the in the book to make
a version of that and then I show the
people that come after me my graduate
students who have received their PhDs
nine of them in just 14 years and that's
you know they're they're as close to
being ideological children those
biological children offer you hope that
you that you transmit the good aspects
of your personality and not your
neuroses and combine them and in issues
though of course you still prioritize
it's alright you're gonna be having
fourteen years exactly fourteen more
years of hugs no that's right pretty
much exactly told me take my word for it
she'll get possibly as many as 18 and
then they'll resume sooner for her as
well alright so the science News had an
interesting pithy little quote
correlated to all this when dust gets in
your eyes we can see things that aren't
there
the same goes for the gleam of the Nobel
Prize yeah you could have done that it's
what scammed a little it rhymed yes it
could be reflect to get my friend Ray
Armand shroud he or she could craft it
into some fencer and what am I chopped
liver well I can manage I can manage a
simple dog roll yeah well you know the
old by the way you mentioned the Bechdel
test yes
it's it's very very common
misinterpretation that it's a test
whether or not two women and a movie are
talking about anything other than a man
it's not true there are tons of tons and
tons of movies that pass that version of
the back bill test it's whether or not
they are talking about relationships
mmm you see you know this steel
magnolias and and French fried tomatoes
and all of those things there are many
many movies in which two women are on
screen talking about something other
than a man it's true it's whether or not
they're talking about relationships but
instead talking about Jesus are we gonna
solve this alien you know there are
actually some free Bechdel test examples
of that yeah how do we balance the
objectivity of science requires with our
very human drives and ambitions what
kinds of structures incentives have been
the Westlake data to encourage this of
course I've thought about this a fair
amount because I'm on the advisory board
for NASA's innovative and advanced
concepts group and the question of how
you can give up seed grants in ways that
encourage the simultaneous benefits of
competition and collaboration yeah well
that's been a question for the
Enlightenment which ever since we
started creating these new institutions
like the US Constitution and and even
back to Galileo I mean it's right the
notion that scientists are just
dispassionate pursuers of facts and
accumulators like wikipedia was that
walk I think that's that is a stereotype
and that's all it is
Galileo the first you know human being
to use a telescope to study the heavens
he was you know utterly trying to
convince the world of the Copernican
principle
ilysm so everything had to be flowing
from that principle namely when he had a
theory of how the tides how high tide
and low tide work it was really based on
the fact that the Sun is the center of
the orbit of the earth and as the Earth
rotates and revolves they did water on
the ocean sloshes back and forth like it
doesn't about is utterly wrong it's not
why we have tides but he wanted to
convince himself so he saw every piece
of evidence through that lens literally
and he did so at the telescope as well
and we wanted to see inflation we wanted
to see it not just to win a Nobel Prize
I think that was always I mean I still
hear that if you detect it you could
still win your Nobel Prize and I think
that really misses the point because I
think that leaves a scientist
susceptible to one of the most
pernicious forces that there is which is
biased confirmation bias when you end up
discarding evidence that doesn't agree
with your preconceived notions now if I
could just butt in here a little bit and
argue with you you know I've been
writing a lot about transparency and the
good side of human competition sure when
it's all in the open and when we're
collaborating in the macro sense of
creating an environment within which joy
joyful competition can take place fair
competition and the destruction of
American politics is an example of where
a collaborative system that allows the
benefits of competition to flower and
I've often pointed out that one of the
things that is being used against
science right now is the notion that we
are lemmings who follow the paradigm
with rigidity when in fact scientists
are among the most competitive humans
that have ever been created it's just
that we believe that the competition is
constrained by all sorts of things like
traditions and and fair play and above
all objective reality right so you know
you wonder in the you know I think the
transparency is wonderful and I think
that is a
you know not not a utopian notion but in
science if the scientific marketplace of
ideas is not a free market if there are
dogmas that really prevail if there are
funding institutions that go to the same
people year after year after year the
same groups the same laboratory then I
don't think you have a free market and I
don't think the competition is fair and
I look back and I say you know in the
book the exact same words that Alfred
Nobel put in his will that the Nobel
Prize was to award things for the
benefit of mankind are written on the
lunar plaques on the lunar landers that
are sitting on the moon right now it
says we came in peace for all mankind
now does anybody think that we came that
was the whole reason was to benefit
mankind it was a part part of it
competition was sure good in that case
right but I think a lot of it was to
establish the United States and in an
anon hot cold war against the Soviet
Union and and that had its purpose and
then you see that the moon has lay
fallow for the last 50 years plus so how
much could the moon have been of getting
there benefited humanity it should have
benefited us much more we should be
there now we should have been
investigating it but the same thing
happened at the South Pole once it was
reached as it was conquered once the
flag was stuck into the ground the
competition some seems to subside and I
see that happening in science too we
would just like to thank our partners
the library for putting on this evening
tonight and our speakers David Brin and
Bryan Keating
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you